sup bad fish obviously after I made the
lego movie a monster hit 468 million
dollars worldwide not that I'm counting
of course it seemed clear to everyone
that the world needed more of me the
Lego Batman movie is a way for me to
give back to my fans with a glimpse into
my real life of fighting crime and
brooding heroism i blushing super hard
under the mask Borrego I think it's
wonderful that the world gets to see a
different side of Master Brook I mean
Batman
but there's a lot more to Gotham's Dark
Knight that meets the eye for instance
did you know that Batman has recently
adopted the son hello secret camera dick
here looks up to me in every way well of
course I do
we are the best team ever the idol S is
me to no end
I want to be just like you when I grow
up Padre little guy wants to grow up to
be a crime-fighting vigilante superhero
just like me no matter how dangerous and
illegal it is look dad it's the back
dude but don't call me dad just go to
your room okay oh I've been parented we
all know that Gotham City has a long
history of crime and my dad did a great
job cleaning things up but that was then
and this is now this movie reflects a
new Gotham City and my Gotham City High
where heroes can team up and fight
climbed yep I can wear my costume too
well luckily for us you left your
costume back in red that's perfect
yeah the suits at the studio thought my
dark life of fighting crime alone needed
a few more heroes in it even though I
really don't need anyone at anytime ever
because I'm totally awesome and Batman
works alone come on Batman let's get
grooving fact is I'm a team player so I
said cool as long as they don't bother
me or touch any of my stuff
hey Batman I'm rubbing my butt all over
your stuff we're gonna have to renamed
as the butt mobile well obviously on
Batman's greatest enemy no matter how
much he may deny it so when the studio
asked me to be the main villain in this
movie I left it the chance to work with
them again I mean let's face it there is
no Batman without the Joker we go
together like coffee and doughnuts
lapell flowers and rubber chickens
mayhem and destruction and what I love
about this movie the most is that it
finally takes the time to explore my
sensitive side I mean yes I am a master
criminal slash improv comedy genius but
I'm also a nice guy and what's Batman
finally realizes this I won't be just
smiling on the outside I'll be smiling
on the inside too that'll be a nice
relief and nobody's got a smile like you
mr. J Thank You Harley just wish Batman
with notice once in a while
hahaha I love it
this movie has everything action scenes
chase scenes building cool stuff
explosions Batman running Batman
Building balancing the city I mean
everything it's about learning the value
of teamwork and family experience the
very emotional story of a young English
lad with a dream that he's held since
childhood to become the most popular
Butler the most famous Butler in motion
picture history it's the story of a
misunderstood criminal genius an epic
tale about one woman's bravery to
challenge a city and their hero and make
the world a better place in the end
everyone loves and respects me forever
which i think is important
we're like a bad family family might be
a bit strong I was gonna say more like
me and my biggest fans or you answer
awesome team it's called the Lego Batman
movie just saying are you such a great
Padre what are you doing trying to give
you a big old hug though you were
attacking me Batman why did you build
this thing with only one seat cuz last I
checked I only had one but
yeah Bruce your greatest fear is snakes
no clouds no it's being a part of a
family again
no now it's snake clouds because you put
that idea in my it sir you need